soon after the publication of deep
shadow maps many facilities started to
address the complexity of rendering deep
shadows deep image
compositing deals with compositing
scenes involving a large number of
elements such as trees or jungles and
atmospheric elements such as fire smoke
or fog previously a single value was
stored at each pixel in the image deep
compositing allow multiple values per
pixel each with its own distance from
the camera this provided new
capabilities including being able to
remove or alter the color or position of
objects within a single element or to
compute post-render depth of field for
their influential research and
publication of fundamental concepts of
deep shadowing technology the academy
presents a technical achievement award
to
thomas lokovic and eric veach gentlemen
back when the internet was young if you
can imagine
uh when he was my professor at cmu the
late andy whitkin uh made a connection
for me he introduced me to tony apodaca
at pixar and tony took a chance to hire
me as a new grad to work on render man
and so to those two guys they basically
got me started and i owe them a great
deal
uh i'd like to thank uh the whole
renderman the amazing renderman team uh
at pixar and the artists at pixar and
other studios and uh the people who
in pixar and elsewhere have uh developed
as we'll see tonight uh deep shadows in
a number of other interesting directions
uh special thanks to adam woodbury tom
duff rob cook matt farr
john mccarthy uh for their help along
the way and i'd like a round of applause
for my kids emma lucy and jack and my
amazing wife melissa thank you
i've been away now from graphics for
quite a while
but i remember the best thing about
working on films was just being around
people who were so energetic and
creative and fun and tonight has really
brought those memories back so thank you
all for that
you